is there a pressure when you're in the
pods and you start to have these
feelings like is there pressure like I
got to tell this girl how I'm feeling
right now
because there's like seven other dudes
that might do it
or do you are you more I mean it could
be that way there were couples like well
obviously Barnett had a lot of
interested suitors there were people who
were seem to attract more than others
but for Lauren and I I think for one we
made it clear to other people who we
were interested in we weren't ourselves
really interested in anyone else beyond
like a friendship type of thing from
that moment it's just like other dates
were kind of like okay well this is more
of a friendship so that's how treat two
dates even at times like I will go in
and take naps when I knew that it wasn't
somebody who I was romantically like
destined for us like hey we got two
hours in here are you down to take a nap
yes some of the dates were long and it
might be with someone that you knew
already or early in the process that you
know you weren't gonna be getting it did
you realize that this was like a
three-step process that this was like
not that the love is blind part of the
show is one of you know kind of three
bigger parts we're gonna have surprise
we knew the premise of the show that you
meet this person
if you move forward you get engaged and
then possibly get married in